most people will tell you that seeing is
believing let me tell you something you
have to believe it first and then you'll
see it what people tell you isn't
necessarily true they'll tell you don't
talk to strangers but then wonder why
they're not making a new business and
not making new business partnerships
because you have to talk to strangers
they'll say if it sounds too good to be
true it probably is and then wonder why
nothing good happens to them because
anything good comes along they're
sabotaged because they think if it
sounds too good to be true it probably
is they say money doesn't grow on trees
and then
and then go around their whole life
thinking that you can't make money with
nothing and technically paper money that
we see in callers money actually does
literally grow on trees
you know they say you can't have your
cake and eat it too what's the point of
having a cake if you're not going to eat
it it's crazy it's stupid so watch the
pennies and the pounds look after
themselves but then they spend so much
time looking after the pennies they miss
the million don't listen to what
everybody says do what's in your
intuition and go be great